the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok so I thought I'd begin today with as
we're coming to the end of the sort of
focus on linear algebra and moving on to
a little probability a a little more
optimization and a a lot of deep
learning so this was like my way of
review to write down the big
factorizations of a matrix and so my
idea and it's kind of enjoyed it as
checking that a number of free
parameters say in L&U or in q and r or
every each of those that the number of
free parameters agrees with the number
of parameters in a itself like N squared
usually so a usually has N squared and
then can we replace a if after we've
computed Ln you can we throw away a yes
because all the information is in L and
U and it fills that same n by n matrix
well that's kind of obvious because L is
a lower triangular and the diagonal all
ones is not are not free parameters and
U is triangular upper triangular and
it's diagonal the pivots those are free
parameters so that but can I just write
down the count so so I'll go through
each of these just quickly after I've
figured out how these are the sort of
the building blocks so how many free
parameters are there in these two
triangular matrices well I think the
answer
1/2 and n minus 1 and 1/2 and n plus 1
that's a familiar number that's the some
of you recognize that as the sum of 1
plus 2 up to n and you have one free /
in the in the upper triangular you
you've got one free parameter up in the
corner 2 in the next one and as you're
coming down you end up with n on the
main diagonal and they add up to that
and you see that those two are different
by n which is what we want okay
diagonal the answers obviously in how
about the eigenvector matrix so this is
this whole exercise is like something
I've never seen in a textbook in and
it's just but for me it brings back all
these key really the condensed course in
linear algebra is on that top line so
how many free parameters in an
eigenvector matrix okay and of course
you're sort of thinking what's the rule
for free parameters so the my answer is
going to be for the number of free
parameters so this is an N by n matrix
with the n eigenvectors in it but
there's a certain freedom there and what
is that what freedom do we have in
choosing the eigenvector matrix every
eigen vector can be multiplied by a
scalar if x is an eigenvector so is 2x
so is 3x so we could we could make a
convention that the first component was
always 1 maybe that wouldn't be the most
intelligent convention in the world but
it would show that that top row of ones
were not to be counted so I get N
squared minus n for that oh yeah well
having done those
- let me let me look at this at this one
does that come out a total then squared
yes because the eigenvector x has N
squared minus n by this reasoning little
hokey reasoning that I just gave and
then there n more for the eigenvalue
matrix and there's nothing left for the
eigen the inverse because it's
determined by x so do you see the count
adding up to n squared for those now I
left open the orthogonal one I think we
kind of talked about that during the
when we met it and it's a little less
obvious but do you remember so I'm
talking about an N by n orthogonal
matrix Q so how many free parameters in
column one that that column is what we
always call Q 1 does it have end free
parameters or is there a condition that
that cuts that back there is a condition
right and what's the condition on the
first column that that removes one
parameter it's normalized it's length is
1 so I only get n minus 1 from the first
column and now if I move over to the
second column how many free parameters
there again it's a unit vector but also
it is orthogonal to the first so to two
parameters got you two rules got imposed
and two parameters got removed so this
is n minus 2 and then finally whatever
so I think that that some of these guys
is exactly the same that we had up here
I think it's also 1/2 and n minus 1 or
1/2 n squared - Adam yeah yeah so not as
many as you might think as the matrix is
size N squared now can I use those
because these are the like the building
blocks can I just check these let's see
just go along the list L times u so L
had this and you had that and when I add
those it adds up to N squared right the
minus cancels the plus and the half N
squared twice gives me N squared so good
for that one
what about Q R well R is upper
triangular like so and then Q oh yeah we
just got it right there so for Q times R
it's that Plus that again adding to N
squared good for that one and squared
for that one this one we just did N
squared minus N and X and on the
diagonal total N squared what about this
guy what about the Big O really
fundamental one that I would normally
write the matrix as s instead of a to
remind us that it that the matrix here
is symmetric so I'm not expecting ensk
where'd for a symmetric me I should have
put that on my list
what's the count for a symmetric matrix
s here so I'm not expecting to get N
squared I'm only expecting to get the
number of symmetric s what's the number
of free parameters that I would that I
start with that I hope will reappear in
Q and lambda so how many what's the deal
for a symmetric matrix let's see I'm
free to choose is it the same count as
this yeah because I'm free to choose the
upper triangular part and the diagonal
but I'm not free to choose the lower so
so I'd say it's 1/2 n times n minus 1
and plus sorry diagonals in there ok so
do I get that
half of N squared plus n from these guys
well I probably do the diagonal guy
gives me in this gives me n and that's a
Q which is my other favorite number
there and when I add that to that that
becomes a plus sign and I'm good yeah
you see how I enjoy doing this right but
I'm near the end but the last one it's
kind of not well known okay Q time says
do you remember that factorization
that's a called the polar decomposition
it's a it's an orthogonal times a
symmetric and it is often used in
engineering as a way to decompose a
displacement or strain matrix anyway Q
times this and it actually it is very
very close to the SVD and I have friends
who say better to compute Q s than the
SVD and then just move along anyway Q
times this so Q is this guy and s what's
s symmetric that's this guy
so that's Q let me write that letter Q
and s so I don't lose it
what are those add up to and squared
happy ok so finally the SVD friendly the
SVD what's the count
well now I don't know I've got
rectangular stuff in there so I've got
to I'm ready for this one and I have to
think a little bit
and we may have done this so I have I
let's suppose that M is lesser equal M
suppose that it is yeah otherwise we
would just transpose and look at the SVD
so let's say M less or equal n so let's
say it's got full rank and what's the
largest rank that the matrix can have M
clearly full rank M so the SVD will be M
by M let's remember the the you the
Sigma and the V transpose this will be M
by n and this will be n by n for the
full scale this VD and if the rank is
equal to M then I really expect to get I
expect it to add up to the total for a
for a the original a has MN right it's
an M by n matrix the matrix a is M by n
with them less or equal in giving me
these things so has MN parameters so do
we get M times n from this I hope we do
I know how many we get from Sigma what
how many what's the count for a Sigma M
and what's the count for V so that's an
N by n and what's the count for you okay
yeah they're orthogonal matrices so that
I should be able to go up to that line
this was an M by M one so that's is that
a half and n minus one am i copying that
correctly out of this circle there
that's that's an M by M orthogonal
matrix Oh
but I have to write in that was foolish
okay em em yeah because that matrix
it's a size M so that's an M and then I
have that and then I have whatever V
transpose end by n oh what's the deal in
there hmm
do I want all of the 1/2 + n minus 1 Oh
God I thought I'd got this straight
does he know I meant I could subtract
this from this and and find out what I
should say whoa
students have been known to do this too
let's see well let's try to think anyway
so I have this n by n submit this n by n
orthogonal matrix so it's first it could
it could be any orthogonal matrix yeah
but is it only the first M columns that
I really need the rest I could just
throw away so I let me try to imagine
that it's just the first well then I
won't have any end in here so maybe I
better take 1/2 and you know help oh oh
yes of course
ha I've got only M columns that matter
the bait the everybody sort of now
understands that SVD we've got the right
the rank is am don't forget that ok then
the first the the first are the first M
columns of V are important those are the
singular vectors that go with nonzero
singular values that really matter so
that's and the rest really don't matter
so
so I'm going to just I have to count how
many so here sorry V the the important
part of thee has has how many and only M
columns but it's an N by n matrix and
those columns are orthogonal so honor
the answer is not MN for this guy its I
have to go through this foolish
reasoning again I have n minus 1 plus n
minus 2 plus so on plus n minus M there
were n minus 1 parameters in the first
over thought oh vector or a unit vector
n minus 2 in the second one up to n
minus M in the third and then V has some
more columns that are coming really from
a null space that that are not are not
important
I believe this is the right thing to do
I'm hoping you agree and now I I mean
I'm hoping even more that those that up
to M times in okay I have a half and
square they have to total this thing
okay this had m m terms
so there's m m of these ends and then I
have to subtract off one plus two plus
three up to M and so what am i
subtracting off what's that some one
plus two plus three stopping at M it's
one of these guys one-half is it 1/2 mm
plus one yeah 1/2 m m plus 1 sorry 1/2 m
m plus 1 I would supposed to enjoy this
and now little nervous but okay so I
believe that that
is that okay well we have the MN that's
a good sign that we're shooting for so
does the rest of it add to nothing well
I guess yeah I guess it does when I put
these two together I have 1/2 mm plus
one and then I'm subtracting it away
again so I get amen
all right well we wouldn't anything
before I raise that board and consign
that to history is there should I pause
a little more minute this will be like
I'm hoping a one-page appendix to the
notes and the book and you'll see it but
I do have one more count to do and then
I'm good with this review and ready to
move onward to the topic of saddle
points and ready to move onward after
that well I'll say a little bit about
the next lab homework that I'm creating
and then our next topic will be like
covariance matrices it a little
statistics this week and then we and we
get a week off we could to digest it and
then come back for gradient descent and
deep learning and and those things okay
everybody happy with that so what's my
final question my final question is the
SVD for for any any matrix of rank R so
it's an M by n matrix but the rank is
only R
it's a natural question how many
parameters are there in a in a ranked R
matrix and that may be we may even have
touched on this question and I have two
ways to answer it and one way is the SVD
so let me and that'll be similar to what
I just pushed up there so if the rank is
our the SVD of this typical rank our
matrix will be u Sigma V transpose but
you know this is the like the condensed
thing where I've thrown away stuff
that's automatically zero because if the
rank is only our like if the rank was
one suppose the rank wasn't one then I'd
have one column times one sigma times
one row right and I could do that count
for R equal one now I have our columns
so this is M by are there Sigma is its
diagonal of course so I'm gonna get our
numbers out of that and this one is now
R by n in other words maybe I should
like save this little bit here that was
helpful
but now I've got M is reduced to R so I
believe that if I count these three I'll
get the right number of parameters for a
rank R matrix and that's not so obvious
because the rank R matrices are not a we
don't have a subspace if I had a rank R
matrix to another rank R matrix
well the rank could be as big as 2r and
probably will be so so we you know it's
just a little interesting to get your
hands on matrices of rank R because
they're kind of a sin like a well math
person would call it a manifold some
kind of a surface
in matrix space yeah have you ever
thought about matrix space so that's a
vector space because we can add matrices
we can multiply them by constants we can
take the NIR combination so they're
there we could call them vectors if we
like that would be a vector space of M
by n matrices what would be the
dimension of that space support so the
vector space of all three by four
matrices that that has what dimension
1212 because you've got 12 numbers to
choose and it is a space because you're
gonna add now if I say 3 by 4 matrices
of Rank 2 I don't have a space anymore
that word spaces is is priscilly asleep
reserved for meaning vector space
meaning I can take combinations but if I
take a rank 2 matrix plus a rank 2
matrix I'm not so it's sort of a surface
within 12 D the to the 3 by 4 matrices
of Rank 2 and we're about to find the
dimension of that surface does your mind
sort of visualize the surface in 12
dimensions yeah well give it a shot
anyway and but what that surface could
have the 11 dimensional so to speak like
meaning locally the it wouldn't have to
be a plan 11 dimensional plane going
through the origin in fact it wouldn't
go through the origin because the origin
won't have rank are so so it's some kind
of a surface and maybe it's got some
different pieces probably some smart
person knows what that surface looks
like but we're just going to find out
some sense something about its number of
parameters as local dimension well I
know that this answer is R cuz I've got
our Sigma's and this one I'm pretty good
at but now it's not
it's R by n so it's instead of here here
our was M but now down here R is R so I
think it's are n minus 1/2
what's that is that an M so now it's an
R R plus 1 I think I think and what
about the u so U is going to be similar
except instead of the end here we've got
an M I so I think we for you will will
have M minus 1 plus M minus 2 plus so so
let me write it here M minus 1 so you
I'm talking about you here it's got our
columns the first one has M minus 1
because I throw away one because it's a
unit vector up to M minus R ours column
okay and now so how what what is that
add up to well I put all the M's
together so that's our M let me say mr
and then I'm subtracting off 1 plus 2
Plus 3 up to R now tell me again what
that adds up to one plus two plus three
stop at our that's what we had here and
we've got it for V and we've got it
again here minus 1/2 our R plus 1 you
okay with that
and now I just want to add them up so I
have M R and I've n R and then I have
two of these so let me let me get it
here M R and n are and now I have to
look at so mr check n are checked now I
have two of these guys so they combine
into R squared plus R and then I R
squared
yeah minus R squared
sorry they combined into minus R squared
plus R and then here's a are coming in
with a plus I think we have a minus R
squared and that is the right answer
yep okay so I took a bit longer than I
intended but it this is a number that
that's sort of interesting
I mentioned saddle points sort of like
separately from maxima and minima just
because they are definitely not as easy
to work with you understand what I mean
by saddle points matrices involved have
are not positive definite those would go
with a maximum they're not negative
they're not negative they're not well
those would go with maxima and minima
but we're we're looking in between so
saddle points okay well I'll get going
on those okay I I sort of realized that
there are two main sources of saddle
points one of them is when I have
problems that when I let's say I
minimize so this will be the constraint
saddle points have come from the
constraint so LeBron Lagrange's gonna be
responsible for these saddle points so
we might have some minimum problem like
minimize some positive definite thing
and of course if we don't say anymore
the minimum is zero right because
otherwise it's positive but we're going
to put on constraints ax equal B so this
is the classical constrained
optimization problem quadratic cost
function linear constraints we could
solve this exactly but let's just see
where saddle point is going to rise so
so there's
is positive-definite but now how do we
deal with that problem well the ground
said what to do Lagaan said look at the
Lagrangian okay he introduced lambda so
this X is in this X is in n dimensions
that's an N by n matrix but I have M
constraints so the matrix a is M by n
I've M constraints and then I'm going to
follow the rules and introduce M lagron
smalt appliers
that's an M and then the neat part of
the groan and what what is this well
it's I take the function and then I
introduce remember lambda is a vector
now not just a number
we had some application where it was
just there was just one constraint but
now I have M constraints so I take a
lambda so lambda transpose times ax
minus B and the plus or the minus sign
here is not important I mean you can
choose it because that'll determine the
sign of lambda but either way it's
correct
okay so we've entered it we've
introduced a function that now depends
on X and also on lambda and and there's
a and they multiply each other in and my
point is that lagron says take the
derivatives with respect to X and lambda
so that's the cool thing that he's
contributed he says if you only create
my function now you can take X
derivative and lambda derivative that
will give you n equations for the X's
from this one from the X derivative and
M equations from the lambda to
it'll be n plus M it'll determine the
good X and the lambda but I'm saying it
that's all true and all important but
I'm saying that the X and that pair X
lambda will be a saddle point of this
function this function has saddle points
not not a maximum okay
let's just take the derivatives and see
what we get so the derivatives with
respect to X D by DX I'm ex is now a
vector so I really should say the
gradient in the X direction I get I get
SX and here the derivative of the spec
2x what that's that is a transpose
lambda because this is the dot product
of a transpose lambda with X you you
know I've put parentheses around it and
followed the transpose rule so that's
the dot product of a transpose lambda
with X it's linear in X so it's
derivative is just a transpose lambda
and that's and now I take the other one
the the lambda derivative the lambda
derivative this doesn't depend on lambda
the lambda derivative is just a X minus
B it brings back the constraints so
that's pretty simple no it doesn't even
require much thought because you just
know the constraints are coming back and
of course B should be put over on this
side because it's a constant so there we
see to a block we see a important very
important class of problems and the
matrix we're seeing we could write this
in block matrix form s minus a transpose
oh I'm going to change that to a plus
because I'm more of a plus person okay a
transpose
and a yeah yeah when I when I took the
derivative this break the lambda I
didn't put the minus sign in here and I
didn't want to so let's make it a plus a
and then there's no nothing there and
the X and the lambda and the zero and
the B that is the model of a constrained
minimum a minimum problem with
constraints it's a model because the
function here is quadratic and the
constraints are linear it's a you know
it's in in course six it's everywhere
constant constantly appearing as the
simplest model okay and my point today
is just that solution X lambda that that
that total solution the the X together
with a lambda that that is a saddle
point of the lagrangian function l it's
a saddle point not a minimum it's sort
of a minimum in the X direction because
this is positive definite that makes
that makes that as a function of X it's
going up but somehow the appearance of
lambda makes this matrix indefinite it
starts positive definite but it has this
a transpose a and that zero
it couldn't be Popeye look at that
matrix I see it's not positive definite
what do I see him why do I say that
immediately when I look at that matrix
it's not a positive definite matrix
because when I see that zero on the
diagonal that shoots positive definitely
couldn't be take take as an example s
equal three 1 and 1 0 take that matrix
just random smell I made it to buy 2
instead of size n plus in do you see how
do I know that the eigenvalues of that
matrix one is plus and one is minus the
determinant is negative so that tells me
right away that one is plus and one is -
thanks yes yes determinant is negative
and somehow here the determinant is
similar calculation would produce a
transpose a or something with the - cuz
I'm going this way well I could I could
do better than that but you saw the
point that that matrix that simple
example of this is has eigenvalues are
both signs let me just quickly say and
I'll put it in the notes or in that
chapter I guess it all this is coming is
still 3.2 the that was originally 4.2
and and you'll see it so what do I want
to say I'd like to say that that example
is pretty convincing to me that that
these KKT matrices if if you talk to
people in in optimization that's kirusha
kuhn and tucker three famous guys and
these are the KKT conditions that that
they derived following lagrosse right
and my point is yeah and this is a
typical sort so it's it's an indefinite
matrix I believe it has that one if I do
elimination yeah tell me this this is a
good way to look at it suppose I do
elimination on on this one or on this
one well suppose
I do elimination there what is the first
pivot three positive so now let me turn
down to here what if I do elimination on
this block matrix then I start up here
and I and that first pivot is positive
again right this is s is a positive
definite matrix don't forget
in fact the first n pivots will all be
positive because the first and pivot
search you're working away in this
corner and if you only if you're only
thinking about the first n this corner
is size n by n then you you don't even
see a you're doing some subtractions and
I'll do those but the pivots themselves
are coming all coming from s and S is
positive definite so we know that one of
the tests for a positive definite matrix
is all pivots are positive so I think
all n of the first pivots will be
positive and and when we use them let's
just see what happens when we use them
[Applause]
so so here's the KKT matrix that I start
with and what do I end up with well
really what I'm doing is I'm multiplying
that block row by something to and
subtracting to kill that a I'm so the
these rows well near enough let me let
me do block elimination block
elimination is like easier I don't have
to write down all little tiny numbers so
I just want to multiply this row by
something tell me what and subtract from
this second row except I suppose there
are numbers or letters I guess they are
letters what do I multiply that first
row by and subtract
let's see if these were just little tiny
numbers as like in 3 1 1 0 what do I
multiply that row by and subtract from
this I multiply by a / s right I do
multiplied by a / s which puts an A
there then I subtract so here I'll
multiply by a / s but I these are
matrices so while I multiply by s by a
SN I'm multiplying by a s inverse times
this s I get a and then I subtract and I
get to 0 and when I multiply by this guy
and subtract I get minus because I'm
subtracting this thing - a s inverse a
transpose that was block elimination
which just in other words it's just I
you've learned about 2 by 2 matrices you
know 3x plus 4y equals 7 and stuff now
I'm just doing it with with with blocks
instead of single numbers but you see
this produced those positive pivots and
what can you tell me about that matrix
what what kind of what can you tell me
about the signs or the eigenvalues or
whatever of this matrix suppose this was
the identity what could you tell me
about - a a transpose
- a a transpose a my voice should
emphasize that - it's that matrix there
is negative definite so although the
next set of mm pivots that come from
here we'll all be negative so I get M
rather n n+ + n- pivots
and and then I remember that the pivots
actually have the same sign as the
eigenvalues that's just a beautiful fact
we know that for for positive definite
ones the eigenvalues are all positive
the pivots are all positive but it's
even better than that that if we have
some mixture for the signs of the pivots
that tells us the signs of the
eigenvalues that's really neat fact so
I'll just write that down signs plus and
minus signs of pivots give us the plus
or minus signs of the I ganache
so I've sneaked sneaked in a nice matrix
theorem that prefer for symmetric
matrices this is symmetric matrices okay
that's what I wanted to say about
constraints and saddle points coming
from there and then I want to say
something about constraints and not
constraints now I'm going to look at the
second source of of saddle points so
these are the saddles from this
remarkable function that we know so I
now have a symmetric matrix S could be
even positive definite usually it is
here do you know what the name for R is
it's a ratio or a quotient it's named
after somebody starting with our who's
that really right it's a Rayleigh
quotient
and what is the largest value possible
value of the Rayleigh quotient we've
seen this idea it is the maximum value
of that Rayleigh quotient of that ratio
is is lambda max right lambda one the
biggest one and the exit does it is the
eigenvector right so max is is lambda 1
and at X equal Q because Q 1 transpose s
Q 1 over Q 1 transpose Q 1 so I'm
plugging in this winner and s Q 1 is
lambda 1 Q 1 right it's the first
eigenvector and so a lambda 1 comes out
so I get lambda 1 I know everything
about that and what I know is if I put
in any X where do I know if I put in any
X whatever and look at this number what
do I know about that number it's smaller
than lambda 1 or it might hit lambda 1
but it's not bigger that's why Maxima
are easy you put in any vector and you
know what's happening you know it
doesn't it's it's not above the max
obviously and what about the min what's
that's equally simple of course it's at
the bottom so what would be the minimum
of that really of that quotient if I was
looking for
what eigen vector and eigen value will I
find when I look at the bottom of this I
will find lambda and the last guy lambda
min
and the I think where the X will be its
eigenvector and again this stuff will
equal lambda n so that's easy I know
that if I put in any vector whatever
just choose any vector in n dimensions
and compute R of X what do I now also
know about our that our of that vector
it's greater than lambda and below the
max above the men but now if I put in
now what about the other lambdas well
the point is that those are saddle
points the beautiful thing about this
Rayleigh quotient is its derivative
equals 0 right at the saddle point at T
at the eigenvectors and and its value at
the eigenvectors is the eigenvalue so so
i have you see what i'm saying i have
lambda 1 here a max lambda and here a
min and in between i have a bunch of
other lambdas which are saddle points
and if i put an x in to the 2 r of x and
look to see what happens i have no idea
whether I'm on this side the below it or
this side above lambda I so the saddle
points are more difficult and take a
little more patience so that's the other
source of saddle points and I so these
are so let me just emphasize again what
I'm saying at lambda at X equal Q K I
have some number the
our ex has some number of positive
eigenvalues and some number of negative
ones for the things above and below QK
okay I've run out of time to to follow
up on the saddle point part of that on
the details of this picture I might
that'll be in the notes and I might come
back to it at the very start of next
time but I will before that you will
have the lab number three and then I
think we should discuss it because I
haven't done this lab it's it's intended
to give you some feeling for overfitting
and also intended to give you a little
introduction to deep learning and so
I'll get it to you and we can talk about
it Wednesday and again it won't be due
until the Wednesday after break okay
thanks so I'll see you Wednesday